and then he says do you want to go on
Dancing with the Stars and I think I
don't even remember what happened like
just watching back I was like oh that's
what happened because I was just like
you had talked before about like hey you
wanted to do Dancing with the Stars mhm
that wasn't offered to you how are
things that you know what things are
good yeah I think it was just one little
falling-out with a specific somebody
that we all know that how that happened
with Dancing with the Stars it was just
that one thing and I think we've all
just moved forward okay
yeah a couple years ago I sat down and I
interviewed you about the fact that you
were frustrated with the franchise you
felt you'd been kept from this dream and
this opportunity of doing Dancing with
the Stars and you felt frankly
discriminated against as a woman so how
does this feel for you to get this now
does it feel like a wrong has been
righted I I'm honestly asking your how
you really felt about it
I do I do feel that way I think I just
think it's it goes to show that if
you're resilient and you always are
strong in what you believe in and fight
for what you want and as long as you're
a good person doing those things even if
it takes five years you know something
good will come from it I obviously had
you situations with place where we owned
kids and didn't get along or didn't
agree and I did go through a point Ross
super frustrated because these male
leads kept getting it and I was told I
couldn't and then I got to a point where
I was like you know what that probably
wouldn't have been a great time for me
to go on anyways you know I just got off
the show didn't want to jump into
another one I'll let it go and then I
think all my like podcast listeners and
people that follow me have still just
been rallying for it and wanting to see
it happen and I have I kind of let it go
at this point even though it's still a
dream of mine so for it to come full
circle five years later after you know
like standing strong into what I believe
it feels like yeah like it wronged me
right but I know I actually emailed my
place this morning and robbed
Mills just say it's been a you know
we've we've had some miscommunications
if you will and I just wanted to say
thank you for forgiving me the
opportunity and I think what's so
special about it is like from my
perspective it's really excited about
going out dance you can start it's not
about another show and things like that
it's about that like Kaitlyn didn't
pursuit college because she pursued
dancing she talked and she wanted to go
professional her mother was a
professional dancer so to be part of
something like this was just a
culmination of everything you
experienced and to think that it was
kind of taken away from me five years
ago five years later it's not I mean
it's it's really dancing it's what
brings me the most joy in life and it's
something I've done since I was little
and I even said I remember to say that
to my voice like I don't care if it's on
TV I don't care if I get paid I don't
care I just to be in a dance studio with
professional dancers eight to ten hours
a day doing what I love to do at this
point of my life would would just make
me so happy
so did you hear back from that email
this morning yeah he said that he was so
happy to hear from me and he would love
to have a conversation and you know
friends well we we almost got what we
thought maybe was gonna be another best
moment of your life it wasn't a ring box
it was air pods um look on you two
spaces you both looked paralyzed with
fear Jason were you thinking oh crap she
thinks I'm gonna propose well the funny
backstory here they actually came to me
asking if I'd like to take this
opportunity to propose and after
thinking through it and no forum was
there any pressure just like hey keep
using this is the right time we're here
support it we'll take care of it make it
special and I didn't even bring it up I
mean I shot it down after about a day of
thinking because I'm just like listen
this is a part of our history a part of
our story is next we don't need these
stories to align the same showing etc so
I
but I told Kaitlyn after I said hey I
wanna let you know they came to me I did
decline it she's like thank God I
wouldn't want that to be then so but the
funny thing is when she'll insult by you
the irony and the fact that like a nice
dresser and literally in pants on
because you can't see blowing wigs with
earpods
at 9:00 p.m. my left pocket and of
course she knows it would have been the
ultimate fake out to tell her you
weren't gonna do it and then do it
I know but yeah that that would have
been a third television proposal for
Kaitlyn like they say third time's the
charm but I don't know if you needed to
take that risk
Kaitlyn you're thinking maybe he really
is popping the question right now yeah
that's it went through my mind because I
was because you know you know Chris
Harrison wouldn't get serious or says
something like that you're like what
could he possibly say I know it's gonna
be something like altering like and so
I'm like thinking of anything so I'm
like okay Jason proposed note okay and
then I'm thinking well the only other
thing is that he's retiring it wants me
to take over his job I mean that's you
know that's how serious he was and then
he kind of laughed at that and then it
didn't even cross my mind what he was
about to say and so when he said he's I
got 100% serious I was like okay get it
he'll be and then I thought Jason knew
for sure no that was the best part is
you thought it was a proposal I'm late
my face was not like do you want to go
on Dancing with the Stars and I think I
don't even remember what happened like
just watching back I was like oh that's
what happens because I was just like
I couldn't speak I mean like you you
know you've worked with these people so
long you know these producers they're
they're friends of yours so the fact
that the secret was kept from you I just
think it's awesome does that kind of
blow your mind yeah I mean I love
surprises I usually like people it's
hard to surprise me and I honestly just
had zero idea and I love that they
caught my genuine reaction and I love
that I'll be able to always look back on
that moment and it was really really
special are you rehearsing in your
living room for Dancing with the Stars
are you getting your cardio in is Jason
your partner right now what is the prep
right now good question I don't know
well like look the thing is this is kind
of an unprecedented moment another one
for 2020 um but I don't know what you've
been told like you got the news from
Chris Harrison but have you heard from
anyone on Dancing with the Stars that
they'd given you a playbook for what to
do next
no because I was supposed to go on so
she's just kind of like said
congratulations it finally happened
can't wait for what's next but that's
about all I know right now my mom has
been sending me plenty of some shoes
like this Chris gave us that news it's
like I just want to go in feeling my
best and my strongest amazing and so do
you know anything about the timeline
because filming in LA is starting to
happen again have you been told you
gotta be in Los Angeles at this stage or
how it will work with the pandemic
they're saying around the fall so I'm
not sure
dates because I think they're probably
still working things out but I know
they're planning on the fall okay and I
don't know if they've told you will it
be you're dancing with masks on I really
I really don't know
well they'll probably have to like test
us or something
that's great at costumes though they
could really bedazzle a mask or to you
know know how do you breathe dancing a
very hard cardio and how would you
breathe with the mass we were cheering
Hannah on we got to be there to cheer
you on um have you heard from Hannah or
talked to her since she was just a
bachelor at winner I don't think she's
watched yet but I have heard from her so
so she's reached out to me and said like
how are you doing wha
like but she I don't think she has heard
yet or maybe she knows and she's just
teasing me but she actually just a few
hours ago reached out and starting to
talk to me so maybe yeah we might
actually have a phone call tomorrow
because the season was airing she was
just like sending you a little support
yes exactly
um and last question do you have a dream
partner who would you like to be paired
with yes but it isn't there anymore
Oh Derek no I'll be happy with whoever
they partner me with I just I don't know
I just feel like they're all incredible
they have to be to be on that show so my
dream partner have you heard well like
if you I mean knowing who is on like
look they could bring Derek back
anything happen would you make any
selection right now if Derek was there I
think in lab is really good he's great
yeah he's great
they're all great you're on the show
it's awesome um and have you heard
anything about anyone else
celebrity wise who will be there they
have heard a vague rumor maybe it's just
fan cry for Carole basket
No oh my gosh that's hilarious
if I lived in soldier I can't listen to
care of that there's no way that will
happen we've been I know nobody and last
night means your mom they're all senior
I'm trying to talk about like who could
possibly be on and I think Oh a Cuomo
brother dr. pouchy that means I would
really like to see like Zach
mark-paul Gosselaar okay great just to
feel like a teen dream like you were
obsessed with the pink Power Ranger
you'd probably want her to be there I
love it
[Music]